hello freak [ __ ] but it's also it's I
think the money is spread out through
these royal families and none of the
money goes to the Saudis you know the
citizens know they don't get any of it
there's these royal families that have
[ __ ] hundreds of members and the
money all gets filtered throughout the
family crazy and they each have nine
kids and what's crazy is that that we
didn't used to be the case to like what
the 50s or 60s like whenever they
establish these these empires that right
kind of money they weren't getting oil
out of there once they started getting
oil out of there they just didn't like
you ever seen the growth of Dubai over
the past thirty years
oh yeah like a time-lapse images of the
growth islands pop ups and bars they
make Island yeah they make their own
islands and they have an ocean break to
stop the islands we're getting swamped
but one of the major there's a huge high
rise on one of the islands it just sank
like five feet into the [ __ ] sand oh
my god oh my god they built a high-rise
on sand oh my god yeah I just keep
sinking it's gonna go Lee's Leaning
Tower pieces about what do they do
demolish it you know they bring girls
from the US over there hollow from
Russia they say you want it from Russia
but I hear I hear stories about us girls
to go over there to get that paper they
think they're gonna go get a little
paper get a date one guy you're gonna
date a whole family well you ever heard
with the salt number nine how he used to
rock it now he used to have a disco in
his house and he would pay these girls
extraordinary amounts of money stay
there for months at a time he'd have
like 50 of them there mm-hmm
and he would just come down and go you
let's do it and he would just come down
the disco just [ __ ] slide down the
railing and his gold underwear and just
start dancing laughs just pick one and
throw the dick to her and then go I'll
see you in a week or so and then they
would just stick around do whatever they
had to do they go to the gym work out
get their toes done and he'd pick a new
one all the time
Wow he just said so much
he just one prostitute was like 'hey
that's not good enough yeah I want girls
who are not prostitutes to become
prostitutes yeah
so he just went deep what about Melania
Trump how dare you it's the first lady
son of a [ __ ]
it's equal payday bro she's gonna be of
equal pay when she divorces if she's
waiting and divorced that [ __ ]
you know that she doesn't even want to
live with him she doesn't want to live
with her listen our son he's the only
ten can't kick him out of the school
he's gonna stay in the school 10-year
olds can't move no they can't move they
can't live to watch to be near a dad who
grabs women's [ __ ] or and admits it
or who's the president someone said
something really funny I forget who it
was they said is that the first lady or
is that a flight attendant on the first
flight to Mars yeah she's she's living
with a lot of mixed feelings just look
at a ring yeah that [ __ ] ring good
lord she grew up in a [ __ ] mud town
in Eastern Europe dude that ring is
insane that ring is like how much does
that ring worth let's guess let's say
you guess because I'm sure it's on the
internet I would say her ring is worth
five million dollars I'm going with
twenty really twenty million dollars
mm-hmm
find out find out young Jamie I'm glad
that bold as [ __ ] right there I hope you
noticed that Alyssa Milano calls out was
she calling out Melania Trump cyan't
diamond rings in official portrait why
is he calling out the rings what come on
Alyssa we should get mad at some blood
diamonds [ __ ] is that what it is 25
carat three million dollar ring damn I'm
so wrong what did you pick I said five
it's 25 Terry five carat so what is it
Milana what's her problem i Stu baller
she can't handle it I heard Melania met
Donald on [ __ ] Island which is one of
these islands real
yeah they bring Eastern European women
there and then billionaires show up and
they all just [ __ ]
we got your Richard dude you want to go
to [ __ ] out get an invite if it all goes
sour we're going to block [ __ ] island if
it all goes wrong your wife leaves you
mine leaves me will I click dude not
getting any younger
yeah listen who cares what everybody
says go to [ __ ] Island then we start
going and after a while it's just like
dude what are you doing Tuesday I'm
gonna go to [ __ ] Island alright he'll go
to [ __ ] Island dude we'd be bar backs on
[ __ ] island yeah we'd be hoping that
they would work there we get a job there
I'll carry the ice you carry the beer
come on me I'm [ __ ] Island drinking
Miller Lite on the beach going we got to
get out of here they took our passports
though [ __ ] but we'd be laying down the
real deck cuz these billionaires can't
[ __ ] when he's wounded be getting horny
after a while think so these
billionaires are on viagra and meth and
they just slamming it in yeah they
probably have helmets on like
exoskeletons and make them [ __ ] harder
right like some sort of an artificial
spine that connects at the shoulders
like a football outfit just slamming in
it's viagra meth-fueled dick they get a
doctor that's right they're taking
vitals at all times like they just have
enough viagra so they're there their
veins pump up so fat and thick that they
almost black out it's like a fine line
you got to get them to right to the edge
whether they're seeing like those here
we get punched and you see stars now
they see those stars while they're
[ __ ] yeah almost going out that's
what they're doing and then when they
come they just throw my oxygen mask on
them and rub their feet and they come
they throw the girl right off the yacht
you're spent she's making a spent
cartridge and he's on the girls were
flood they know it's coming they swim to
shore they collect their check they get
on a plane they don't say [ __ ] just a
bidet clean out the undercarriage and
centered center Oh awesome home girls go
Jaguar can
where'd you get that Jenna whatever
I think it's darker than that I don't
think you leave [ __ ] Island
you just stay I think as as the guy is
[ __ ] blasting his last durable inside
you you feel a cold barrel of a handgun
on the back of your head Jesus now this
is baryon [ __ ] Island that's it I guess
if there's certain countries obviously
North Korea right
that guy's killing people left and right
you can get away with killing people in
certain countries like a hundred percent
yeah like he killed his half-brother
he killed who did Kim jong-un hell yeah
he hired someone to do that and they
apparently they didn't know they were
doing it and they were doing a prank
they thought they were doing a prank and
he squirted him with something that
turned out to be some neurotoxin yeah
zapped him and killed him but he killed
some guy who was a general and then he
because he thought that it was like his
uncle that he thought was trying to
reuse yeah I remember that right he
killed his kids too because he didn't
want his sons taking revenge so he
killed his so that's hard so that's
going on right now if that's going on
someone could shoot some crazy corrosion
chick on [ __ ] Island oh yeah so she
didn't document around [ __ ] home now
that's allegedly by the way just in case
the president is listening I bet he
didn't Jesus outstanding man how do you
think he met horrific grooming he met
her on a date she swiped right is it
right right or left right I swipe right
he swiped right parties party begin they
met up at a Starbucks for a coffee date
first he could save Oh see she's upset
of the kim jeong-hoon
[Applause]
[Music]